[Music]  Miley Cyrus has seemingly lived her life  with no regrets  [Music]  well there may be one thing it's kind of  crazy that I'll always be known as  licking a sledgehammer  there's this meme on Instagram that says  how come it's sexy when Miley Cyrus does  it but when I lick a sledgehammer I get  kicked out of Home Depot came in  maile opened up on Long Island's Cooper  Lawrence morning show about her wrecking  ball days the 24 year old is ready to  usher in a new era with her new single  Malibu  [Music]  but for an artist who in the past looked  like what was it Adam sometime from  Lucky Charms Bobby her recent  all-natural hair has fans wondering  what's the deal  I like blonde and brown and I don't have  to choose and I don't want to I don't  want to damage my hair and I don't do  anything to it it is I wake up and it's  a [ __ ] it feels excuse my language it  is like a rat's nest in there  [Music]